people think i have knowledge no my head
is empty that's why to make look little
substantial i have a turban it's totally
empty always but i have clarity clarity
means what you see things the way they
are knowledge means what you have fixed
information about everything if things
have changed you will not see it the way
it is that's as good as being blind see
people think owls are blind it's not
true their vision is far more sensitive
than yours but because of sunlight
they're blinded because it's too much
when light goes down he sees very
clearly not because he's blind because
his eyes are super sensitive so it's
important that you bring clarity to your
life not knowledge because knowledge is
conclusions that you gather knowledge is
okay when you're trying to do something
physical material in the world but not
with life need motivation watch a top 10
on believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best sad guru and my take on his
top 10 rules of success enjoy
is it true
what you thought was absolute at the age
of 12
today is not true
yes or no
are you sure that whatever you think is
this is it right now will be this is it
in another three years time of course
not
you know that so you know you're wrong
[Music]
yes sir no yes so you know
anyway you're wrong so why assert the
wrong things
well right now we are wrong at least
let's manage with little
little more conscious if you know you're
wrong you will walk carefully isn't it
hello
but you you think you're absolutely
correct
then you will do stupid things and you
blunder around the world
if you know you're not seeing properly
will you walk carefully or no
if i ask you to walk through a dark room
suppose we turn off all the lights and
close it down everything pitch dock if i
ask you to walk
suddenly will you become super alert and
conscious as to how you walk
but when the lights are on
you're just going unconsciously bumping
into everybody
so if you learn to walk every moment
like there are no lights
and you're looking at everything
absolutely carefully
then what you see clearly you go through
it what you don't see see clearly you
hesitate some places you take a little
bit of chance
but if you are just confident
you will blunder through life we don't
know where you will get in
and what you will get trapped into
most people
are trapped into their professions their
family situations their social
situations in such a way they all became
like this
yes already i'm saying
not just older people
youth have become like this
what will happen to me at the end of my
life what will happen to me at the end
of my life i'm already revealed the
secret you will die
but
if this happens what to do if that
happens what to do all those things will
happen
it's not that everything will happen in
your life the way you like it things
will happen in the way you don't like it
it once happened sankaran pillai got
fired from his job
simply because he asked a question
smoking or not smoke
[Music]
non-smoking how can you get fired for
asking such a simple question
smoking
or non-smoking he asked and he got fired
because what he was supposed to ask was
cremation or burial
[Music]
so
many times what you do
thinking i am right may be irrelevant to
the situation in which you exist
so the most important aspect of your
life is you're relevant
not right
you're just relevant to the existing
situation you're relevant i am right i
am right i am right
this is confidence
you being right nobody cares all the
idiots who think they're right
nobody wants to listen to them nobody
wants to be around them isn't it
people who always think i'm right i'm
right you want to be around them
no the important thing is you're
relevant to the situation in which you
exist if you have to bring relevance
into your life
you must extinguish your confidence and
bring clarity rule number two be a
full-fledged human you should not be a
motivated person
generally
somebody when we say somebody is
motivated
it means
they have an agenda of their own
life has no agenda
it's for you to be a full-fledged life a
grasshopper is trying to be a full place
grasshopper earthworm is trying to be a
full-fledged earthworm a bird is trying
to be a full-fledged bird a tree is
trying to be a full-fledged tree a human
being should strive to become a
full-fledged human being
is all our businesses
but each one of us start creating our
own agendas
and doing all kinds of things
no no
you're just a piece of life don't take
yourself too seriously
because before you and me countless
number of people have come and gone
[Music]
where are they
all those people
you think they were all idiots
they were all idiots and they died is it
no they were also like you maybe they
were also officers maybe they were kings
more than you
all kinds of things
all topsoil now
this will also become topsoil
just a little bit of time life is a bit
of a sparkle
[Music]
how old is your son
25
so 27 years ago where was he sir
so if somebody is not here we say they
are dead isn't it
27 years ago he was dead
we will give him 100 years
eight years later
he will be again dead
[Music]
yes
27 years ago how long was it that sir
[Music]
long time
so 85 years later or 80 years later how
long will he be dead sir
very long time
so all of us will be dead for a very
long time
we're alive just for a brief amount of
time
yes
very brief amount of time
we will be dead for a very long time i
want you to look at it in this
perspective
how long will you be dead
you can't imagine so let us say
10 000 years we are dead or 100 000
years they are dead or a million years
we are dead all right
how long are you alive compared to that
very very brief what you call as life is
a brief sparkle the only thing that you
have to do is
rise and sparkle as a full-fledged life
when something is needed around us we
will do that naturally
because
when you're doing wonderfully well you
will do what is needed isn't it
when you are miserable you will be
motivated
yes
tell me when you are very happy have you
looked at yourself how nice and
wonderful you are you're willing to do
anything for anybody bend backwards if
necessary yes or no
when you're little frustrated
how difficult it is
so don't teach your children to become
motivated about something these are all
nonsense that's coming from the west all
those trashy self-help books
motivate yourself build confidence
believe in yourself you believed in god
and destroyed so much of this world now
you believe in yourself what will you do
rule number three learn to be alone when
gautama
the buddha was asked
is it better to walk alone
or in company
he said
it's better to walk alone than to walk
with a fool
well
that's him not me
he was quite sure that only a fool will
walk with you
so he said it's better to walk alone
than to walk with the fool
certain lore
in this country
says
when you want to do a short and quick
journey walk alone
when you want to do a long journey
walk in company
but the important thing is
who is walking with you
not always
being together is a good thing
many times
being together can be a nuisance
so
first and foremost
unless you are a twin
even then
we come along and we go
along if one does not know
how to be by himself
or herself
then being together can be a lot of
nuisance
we are referred to as human beings
human beings means
every other creature
is what it is simply because of what it
does
[Music]
but a human being
can simply be
which is a unique quality of the human
being
that we can simply be
that we are not compulsive action that's
what it means
our action
is conscious and judicious
but generally when people get together
generally
people are in compulsive action
it can be an association where there
could be a purposeful action
or it can be
a gang where there can be more
purposeful action
or it can be a crowd which can be a
compulsive action
so essentially to be human means
we have reached that point of evolution
within ourselves
that if we wish we can simply sit here
just be
we can consider
as to what action to take and what not
to take
this is definitely individual
when individuals come together
we say
it's we in
in plural
but still it is individuals who have to
come together
to be an individual means
you are not further divisible
that means
you're just one
people find
different ways to divide themselves
within themselves
in india
with eighteen thousand years of cultural
history
we have invented various words to divide
ourselves
it's very common for people to talk in
terms of atma paramatma ankara this one
and that one
but every every culture has this in
their own way
when things are going right
when good things are being done
if you ask people they say yes i did it
when things don't go right when things
go wrong
then they will try to find somebody if
they don't find anybody
he is always there
when
they are very wonderful
of course they take pride in being how
wonderful they are
when they turn nasty they say it was my
ego
mr ego is always a fall guy
so individual means
but if i'm wonderful it's me
if i'm nasty it's me
all of you
are you 24 hours wonderful
hello
are you 24 hours wonderful
no no sometimes wonderful sometimes
nasty sometimes beautiful sometimes ugly
it's okay
if we understand it is me
who is capable of being absolutely
wonderful
and it is me who is capable of being
absolutely nasty another moment
then
gradually the number of moments of
nastiness will keep on receding
if i see
what is wonderful is me what is nasty is
in india we have many words it's my
karma what can i do
now you must fix this
being an individual is very important
that means you're not further divisible
if i'm wonderful it's me if i'm nasty
it's me
if i succeed it's me if i fail it's me
you have to fix this
rule number four do what you want
just learn to be like god
never intervene in anything
every day in the morning
every kind of idiot will tell you what
you should do today you just listen
just like god
marriage will work it may not work with
your profession
say uh
you're misunderstanding this
you're trying to make this into some
kind of a value system
you're trying to make it your philosophy
i will do only what works
[Music]
well you took a oath i will do only what
works now you don't know what works
because what we what works will not come
with a oath
or a commandment
what works comes with constant
observation
an evolution of who you are isn't it
hello
the same things how you made them work
how clumsily you made something work 10
years ago the same thing you may be
doing it with ease today isn't it so
or you may be doing it clumsily today
you're doing it well at one time
whichever way whichever kind of
evolution has happened
so what works
is not some kind of a formula
it is an evolution of a human being
to come to what works
on all levels of life
uh
this is like really when you
you're just falling out of a self-help
book no i am not a self-help book
do what works
do whatever the hell you want
what's my problem
but what's the point of doing something
that doesn't work
hello
i am not telling you you should do only
what works do whatever the hell you want
but
for your life because it's a limited
amount of time
what is the point doing something that
does not work isn't it
either it should work for you or it
should work for people around you if it
doesn't work for you and anybody around
you what is the point of doing that damn
thing
this happened
soldiers
american soldiers were leaving
on duty
so
one of them told the other
you know steve's wife
she read three musketeers
and she delivered a triplet delivered
triplets
he says oh my god my wife is reading
birth of a nation
what am i supposed to do
that's not how it
works so don't make this into some kind
of an ethic or a philosophy i will do
only what works
well just to see what works
needs a lot of application even for the
smallest damn things isn't it
hello
to do a smallest thing
like hitting a ball or kicking a ball
straight
you know
how much it takes
somebody who can take a ball where he
wants wow the whole world is worshiping
him
just because he kicks a damn ball
yes or no
because people understand what it takes
nobody is worshiping worshipping him
because he kicks a ball
because people can see
what has gone into it
isn't it so
people can see what has gone into
to be able to kick a ball the way he is
kicking what has gone into it is it life
has gone into it
so
don't make philosophies and ethics out
of everything
or don't tell yourself a commandment
i will do only what works
it's a good commandment
but now you don't know what works
so
oh no
you
you need to be conscious and apply
yourself to every damn thing
if you just learn this much
that you don't decide what is important
and what is not important
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five don't deal with
ignorance i would say uh there's
literally no human being
who's not confronted
with a thought and an emotion like that
but they managed to brush this aside
it doesn't bother them enough
the pain of not knowing doesn't tear
them that's the whole problem
they come to terms with ignorance they
make a deal with ignorance they will
build relationships where everybody will
confirm this is the best way to live
off
comfort companionship love affection
these are all things you're
seeking
i know a whole lot of people have raised
human emotions to heavens
if you say love they said divine love
if you say joy they say divine joy if
you say bliss they say divine bliss
you don't need any god's help to be
joyful
loving peaceful
as a human being you're endowed with
these qualities
so all those who deprived themselves of
that
they either seek
god
or they settle for a dog
yeah usually
because
they want a
unconditional love this is a demander
because the nature of love is such that
it's like a flower if you don't watch it
for two minutes it'll fall
it'll wither and fall right there
either you want to
let it fall
or you have to nourish it every moment
or you have to concretize it that means
you take a picture
and keep it on your phone screen
or your institutionalize it with
marriage or this or that
so essentially
well i'm i'm not against any institution
because institutions are needed in the
world to operate otherwise there will be
cures
[Applause]
that is a different thing
but you cannot institutionalize
joy or peace like right now we think
united nations is the institution for
peace
no no you cannot institutionalize peace
you cannot institutionalize joy you
cannot institutionalize
love
or anything for that matter
institutions are functional instruments
in a given society
i have at most respect for them because
without it people a whole lot of people
wouldn't know how to live
you need institutions there is a
government there's a democratic process
there are variety of things all right
there are courts there are parliaments
well uh 90 of the time some nonsense may
be happening there
but still these institutions are
important because without that there
will be total chaos
so i'm not talking against institutions
but
institutionalizing
things that happen within a human being
is a silly effort rule number six make
the most of your life in the yoga
culture
first eight years
or actually eight and a half years
is considered childhood
so these are not counted though
is up to 12. it's the eight and a half
years where you're a real child you know
it from your own experience after you're
eight and a half only your parents
thought you were a child but you are
secretly many things
yes
adults
think that you are a child
but you know you are not one
because
your childhood in many ways ends at
eight and a half
so if you
take two side solar cycles
which is uh
24 years or little less than that
and add eight and a half years to it
it will become
32 and three-fourths or something like
this
32 years and seven months or somewhere
there
the exact calculations we can make
but it's nearly 33 years
so when these two cycles end
plus the
living that when it ends
it is a possibility
this is the time
when your life could take on a different
level of propulsion
if you have prepared yourself well
either with education or some skill or
yoga
or
inner dimensions of your life
if you have prepared yourself on any of
these things
that is the time when it can propel
or that is the time when it can start
crashing
you know in the western societies they
talk about mid-life crisis
it usually starts around 33-34 years of
age
suddenly people don't know what to do
with themselves
life getting meaningless or
those who are successful they find
traction and suddenly they explode into
different levels of success or
well-being
all this can happen
because
within the system
it has completed a certain cycle either
it can take off or it can crash
rule number seven expand your horizons
let one human being honestly say
when you are with your most loving
parents however doting and wonderful
they were to you
that you never felt
this is not where you want to be
that is a dishonest human being
because
love gets tedious
somebody's fondness gets very tedious
comfort gets tedious
because the nature of life is it wants
to constantly expand
if there is no room for expansion it
doesn't matter you are kept in a
uh whatever i won't use because
everybody uses the word golden palace i
think golden palace is totally
unaesthetic in my
my visual perception i hate golden
palace but whatever is the most
wonderful
palace
or as you say shangri-la whatever
you will it'll get tedious
all the heaven-bound people
they don't know how bored they will be
within three days in that place of
goodness
so i'm saying it doesn't matter it's not
because there's something wrong with
your parents
there may be most wonderful people
but
the very nature of a human being is such
only if you're a pet animal if you have
reduced yourself to that you're just
happy
with the meals that you're getting
and
somebody's fondling you once in a way
and you're happy with that
for that you must be a pet animal you
should not be born as a human being once
you're born as a human being it is
natural wanting to break
barriers
so when you're young as a child or a
teenager you think barriers means
they're all physical before you
understand the barriers are not really
physical
whether you build your own house or you
live in your parents house or you live
in a slave master's house
the house and walls are not the barrier
it is all within us
before you realize that or how soon you
realize that
will lead to either transformation or
frustration rule number eight learn to
rest you can simply sit
if you learn to simply set
you'll become tremendously intense
right now your energy is simply expanded
by doing unnecessary
endless
activity when you have so much
mental diarrhea
how can you have energy
suppose you have diarrhea do you see how
weak you feel
yes or no
right now this mental diarrhea that's
why people have no energy
they want to just eat and sleep all the
time
because mental diarrhea is very
exhausting
[Music]
if you have physical diarrhea you know
how exhausting it is
yes
this is also equally exhausting
people are sleeping eight hours 10 hours
a day
not because they're working so much or
their body is in such a bad state
it's just mental diarrhea
if you stop the mental diarrhea there's
enough energy to make this very very
intense
now how do i stop mental diarrhea
if you have diarrhea physical diarrhea
what is the first thing to do
what
yes run to the toilet i know that
i'm saying
as a as a corrective measure what's the
first thing you do
now as a corrective measure what is the
first thing you do
first thing is
stop eating right
i said no
but diarrhea means in some way we've
eaten something
that the body doesn't want
it's trying to throw it out
yes
you've taken something inside which the
body doesn't like
it wants to throw it out
first thing is
[Music]
stay away from food for some time
you eat bad food
and then try to stop diarrhea it's not
going to work
so similarly bad food for the mind is
just this
you have gotten identified with things
that you are not
the moment you get
identified with things that you are not
mental diarrhea is inevitable
it's bad food for the mind now it will
run endlessly do what you want
you do any damn meditation you say shiva
rama it's not going to stop
it's not stopped isn't it
because bad food
is being eaten every day you're getting
identified with more and more things and
you want to stop your mind
you do whatever kind of circus
it is not going to stop
if you disidentify with everything
you understand what is you and what is
not you
if you keep a little distance from that
mind will become still
if you want you can use it otherwise you
can keep it now my hand is there if i
want i can
move it otherwise i can keep it this is
a useful hand
suppose it starts jumping like this
you clearly know
there is some kind of an ailment isn't
it
yes or no
so if hand is jumping you know it's an
ailment
if mind is jumping is it an ailment or
not
the ailment has come
because continuous wrong diet
you tell your mind
that i am this i am this i am that i am
that
it's having diarrhea
you stop giving it wrong food
if you clearly see what even if you do
not know what is me at least you know
what is not me isn't it
this much you do
[Music]
tonight before you go to bed
sit on your bed
and sit down
and discount everything that is not you
this house in your in which you're
living is this me
no
this loving parent
or mother father wife or husband or
child
they're wonderful what is this me
no
now these nice clothes i'm wearing is
this me
no
now my body i like it but
is this me
no now i'm having so many thoughts is
this me
no
now i'm having wonderful emotions is
this me no
like this everything that's not you
before you sleep keep it down and go to
bed
tomorrow morning you will wake up
considerably more intense than today
rule number nine commit to success this
happened
in your school maybe later in your
university later in your work it's
happening to people maybe not everyone
but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then something little
interesting happens here they will go
away here they'll go away there they'll
go with it hey i want to live
their commitment to success is weak
[Music]
either situations around them
in some way
you know situations can impede you from
doing what you're doing very easily many
times it happens to everyone
but
when this happens people weaken their
commitment for their success
maybe physically they'll feel a little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success
maybe their emotions slosh around a
little bit they will weaken
their commitment to success
this is very important right now
however long it takes
this
virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you may stay alive that's an
important part
and
commitment to staying alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very dear to us passed
away all the more important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy
to take care of the people around us
[Music]
so our commitment to success should not
weaken
because there is
social drama going on
or physiological drama or psychological
drama whatever happens your commitment
to success should not weaken
that is what get you across
so many lines in our life so many
barriers in our life
so
what does success look like
what does it take
[Music]
you must understand
those
who made any significant achievements in
their life
ah they did not
[Music]
you know
i don't want to take any personal
examples of anybody i'm trying to avoid
obvious things that are coming to my
mind
[Music]
well
you know i know family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette
and sit there nicely because they're
trying to
become peaceful
[Music]
and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have one tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
[Music]
8 o'clock 8 30 they're back home for
dinner and then maybe other things drink
and this and that and whatever
[Music]
well
that's their priority it's fine i'm not
complaining it should not be that way
but those
who have been very successful either in
music sport art business spiritual
process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they ate when they slept
when they got after known rest i have
not seen such a thing in my life
so
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they're not settling down
wherever it's a bit comfortable
because comfort will happen
when they lure you to in the grave very
comfortable you are you know angry
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is choose your
priorities hello
so just do this one thing stop
discriminating what is important what is
not important
if you pay the same level of absolute
attention to every damn thing
you will see
that
what is the right thing to do is a very
natural process
but you have already decided what is
important what is not important how will
you evolve what is the right thing to do
half the world is already been
given up
because it's not important
you are paying attention only
you even
look at somebody properly
only if they are of something to you
no i looked at everybody absolutely
every life every damn thing every pebble
every moment that was happening in the
earth in the atmosphere everything
not as a study
simply because i had eyes
and i had an attention span
i paid attention to everything
today they are saying this is something
phenomenal i was just laughing and
saying see i just wandered aimlessly
everybody thought i am just a vagabond
but now
this aimless wandering has is paying off
in a huge way
because it doesn't matter what the hell
you're doing small things are big things
if you are absolutely involved
absolutely
you will see
you will know what's the right thing to
do you trying to live here without
involvement
this is why you have morals you have
ideals you have ideologies you have
values you have ethics you have
commandments
because you are trying to live here
without involvement
you want ready-made formula what is the
right thing to do thou shall not thou
shall not thou shall not
did the world get fixed i am asking
every goddamn school growing children
knows what is the right thing to do has
it worked
it's not worked because
you think
there is a substitute for involvement
there is no substitute for involvement
where there is no involvement there will
be no life
so don't try to make formulas
or ideals or ideologies
out of life
all life takes is absolute involvement
unbridled involvement
not distinguishing
who is who what is what just absolutely
involved with everything that you're in
touch with right now
if you do this one thing
well according to your level of
intelligence
and
you know nature also should heal
with all this
you will know what is the best thing to
do given
your perspective of course
see right now
if you bring a man of certain capability
he may do something in a given situation
that's not the right thing to do for you
isn't it
you must know what is the right thing
for you to do in a given situation
you won't be able to do what he does
you must be able to do what you can do
to the best of your ability that is the
right thing to do in your life
you don't try to do like somebody else
so that will be the problem the moment
you decide what is the right thing to do
no
there is no ready-made solution
involvement there is no substitute for
involvement where there is no
involvement there is no life
don't utter the word freedom because
freedom is a consequence it's something
that you have to earn it doesn't come as
a philosophy in 60s we thought it's a
philosophy
if you live responsibly
you will see freedom will come and i say
responsibly not in the sense of civic
responsibility if you retain your
ability to respond to life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond if it is
unlimited it is freedom why does one
person need uh
well by prescription these days
eight hours is it
seven seven to eight hours seven hours
sleep
okay seven
hours and why another person can do with
half of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you are looking at food only as a
protein vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about
a food chain that means
they're all different kinds of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is will
determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so your food appears in front of me if i
just look at it
uh people have prepared it with
elaborate care if i just look at it i
said no
this is a no sad guru
this girl this lady has brought it she's
a very good cook she's very tasty
i just look at it in a channel
simply because it's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty
but it's not alive enough for me
if it's not alive enough i will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is
most people are eating at least 50
50 means 100 more than what they need to
eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you're
eating cut it down by 50
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods you
will see you will neither drop weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you're putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion
of liking the taste or simply by
compulsion of filling yourself
up now the body has to press process so
much food to create so much energy
this extra processing is taking a toll
on the system
the amount of impurities that are there
in the food will also determine how
how much inertia you generate in the
body let's understand it this way in
terms of physical terms what sleep means
is inertia
right now your dynamic this is life
inertia sets
when inertia goes beyond a certain point
that's death but sleep is a certain kind
of death
but it is offering you
rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here if you're a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy
on that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this that's all
you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life
the food will come down sleep will come
down naturally i don't know i never
looked at life as a
series of mistakes learning from that i
don't look at life like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course
but
uh
i wouldn't see them as mistakes i just
see them as part of growing up
and
becoming more mature because
enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly but still operating in
the world you need wisdom wisdom you
have to earn it with experience there is
simply no other way for that today it
has become fashionable with all these
management gurus and all saying you must
learn from your mistakes you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes
i don't believe that you must learn from
your mistakes i would rather live a life
where i don't do any mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave
yeah
yes of course that is what being human
means that we can learn from other
people's experience from history we can
learn we don't have to do all those
things once again and especially you are
from the aviation state
if you are trying aviation or if you're
trying skydiving or something
if you don't do things right the first
time
well that will be the last time there
are many aspects to this fundamentally
if you keep your life energies very
exuberant
now you will see the sleep quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be overleading
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day 10
in the morning 7 in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world
and we are 7 days 365 days we don't know
what's a vacation
because we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so
they never go on a vacation there is no
break there's no sunday monday nonsense
nothing every day something is happening
endlessly
but you will see people are very
energetic healthy sleep is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things a certain
amount of energy and a certain amount of
time
when it comes to time
it is ticking away for all of us at the
same pace clock doesn't run slowly for
me faster for you there's no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy you
are sleeping you are doing useful things
or useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there is no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death
so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day
how long do you want to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody i'm going to
die
for yourself how long do i want to die
in a day
eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours you're dead
means one third of your life dead
another four hours goes into eating
sleeping eating toilet bath this that
where is the time to live i'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time
perception happens to you in five
different dimensions
seeing hearing smelling tasting touching
this is how you're perceiving life
this data data has gathered within you
only because this data has gathered
within you now you're able to walk on a
round planet which spins it's not a
small thing
it is not a small thing that you are
able to walk on a spinning round ball
because all this data has gathered
through five sensors it is not
intellectual information but it is a
perceptional information
if this information is not there you
won't be able to walk actually
you will not be able to walk straight
this is what is happening for people
when some people lose their memory and
things like that suddenly they become
unstable in their body because some of
the data is gotten disconnected with
their system
so
this data that you perceive is most
important that's what a child is all the
time drinking up everything you see how
the child is looking at everything
because he wants to drink up as much
data as possible because instinctively
he knows without the data he will not be
able to function
so how attentive you are
how attentive your eyes are how
attentive your ears nose tongue and
touch is accordingly you have that much
you know that much uh usable information
so why one person is more efficient well
you are an athlete why one person is
able to catch a damn ball another person
can't catch the damn thing
why is it
because that level of attention of
exactly how that ball will behave how
you can anticipate where it will go this
is not there intellectually suppose you
have a phd in football you think you can
play football
uh
if you have a phd i no i think you need
to experience it as well if you just
study it only yeah
no that is that is not experience it's
perception
you are you're watching it out of your
keen interest you're watching exactly
how a ball moves you may not be thinking
the physics of it but you're watching it
and perceiving it because of that
perception you know something that you
cannot know by reading 100 books about
it the notion of the difference between
pain and suffering i thought was very
useful
so pain is physiological it's there it
was no pain most people would not even
know how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain in this
see what all you've done to it
isn't it
see there's no pain in this so that's
why you
took it off if there's no pain in your
nose
maybe you would have taken it off
because there are many advantages you
will take in about 22 extra oxygen if
you just remove this one thing
contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things
suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in los angeles
people would pull out their stomach bag
and
you think they wouldn't do it
probably what
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know i hear in united
states there's one group they call
themselves something i forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that wow
can you imagine this no
in spite of so much pain if there was no
pain
almost everybody would have cut
themselves off in the name of fashion
they would have cut themselves into
ribbons
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are
or how stupid you are
and suffer it a million times over
right now
most human beings are like this what
happened
10 years ago they can still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life
they are suffering the two most
fantastic faculties that human beings
alone have
a vivid sense of memory and a fantastic
sense of imagination
don't pursue enlightenment
you cannot pursue enlightenment
how can you pursue something that you do
not know
if you pursue something you will pursue
only what you know
what is the point pursuing something
that you already know
what is the point
in running after something that you
already know
so if you have to step into something
that you do not know
[Music]
the only thing is just to keep walking
keep a steady direction and keep working
maybe it's the wrong direction it
doesn't matter
just keep walking
after all planet is round
inevitably
if you keep walking and keep straight
walking not round and round
if you just keep straight walking
you will inevitably get somewhere
nobody can take it away from you
you know
if you have a dog at home you would know
this
if you just tickle him in the tail
he will go sh
chasing his own tail
okay a lot of people are doing that
[Music]
their own tail they're chasing
even enlightenment is their own tale
nobody told you there is such a thing
but
definitely you can see
from one person to another person
one person seems to be little better off
simply the way they are not because of
their money not because of their wealth
not because of their qualifications
simply the way they sit and stand
somebody seems to be better off than
somebody else
yes or no
so
there is room and scope for improvement
relentlessly improve
let's see where it gets you
but if you have fancy ideas of what is
enlightenment
then you will chase that silly idea
and that idea is never enlightenment
because it's your idea something will
get you money something will get you
comfort that's not the point
what you choose to do will it give you a
life
when i say give it give your life
are you just trying to make a living or
are you trying to make a life out of
this
this is important
making a living is not an issue
a worm a insect a bird an animal all of
them are making their life making a
living isn't it so they're even making a
life out of it but definitely they're
making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not an issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
i want to live is not a problem i want
to live like you this is a problem
so
it is important if you consider
your life has a precious life
you must make sure you make a wonderful
life out of this in your book you talk
about something i thought was so
interesting to set the faucet to a
certain drip rate and do nothing but
focus on the dripping of the faucet for
like seven minutes or something the idea
is to pay attention to something which
has no relevance to you
see people are
have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me
you divided the universe you will never
know anything this way
indiscriminate focus indiscriminate
attention
i am not attending to you because you
are somebody with a cobra in your heart
all right
it doesn't matter who i speak to who i
am with i'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate does the universe open
up to you
you have discriminated
naturally you close you know people come
to me and say sadhguru i want to walk
the spiritual path
i say okay
be here for three days let's see what we
can do so no such group day after
tomorrow my uncle's daughter's birthday
i have to go
oh you want to get enlightened
and day after tomorrow uncle's
daughter's birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this i said sakura but i don't like this
all right i'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like will do only do that
you won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when
you're so constipated in your head that
you lack only three or four people or
three or four things in your life how do
you want to open up to the existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is
people are thinking it's just breath all
right on one level that is also openness
whether you allow this to happen or you
don't allow it to happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors
you're dying in installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good at least the
neighbors may think so
this may sound very
not so compassionate but i'm saying
everybody dies you and me will die all
right
if you're dead if the game is over
but if you're half dead oh
this is endless torture to yourself
when you are being tortured of course
you'll share it with everybody else this
happened at the cincinnati airport in
ohio united states
people had lined up to check in on the
airline
ticket booth
one man just skipped the line and came
straight in the front and thrust his
ticket
the lady at the counter she said sir
there is a line
he said no no i'm in a hurry
she said everybody's in a hurry you're
on the same plane
please stand in the line
then he said do you know who i am
she looked at him promptly picked up the
microphone and said there is a man here
who does not know who he is can somebody
help him
so who am i
is not a question that you ask somebody
it's a question that you ask yourself
make it more and more profound
unfortunately
in many ways
not just in the way that i said now
in many different ways i would say
70 percent of illnesses on the planet
all kinds
are self-created
even if you get an infection there is a
way if you keep yourself in a certain
way physically and mentally
the virus in the bacteria will not work
the same way as it works upon somebody
else
if you set yourself like this
no matter what's happening
anyway i have to go and do this this and
this
there's no break from that
the last 29 years
i have not been able to cancel one
program because i'm running temperature
i got a cold i got this i got that
it doesn't matter what's happening what
you have to do you anyway have to do you
can't turn back on that
either out of your commitment or you
have a boss like that
one or one way or the other if it
happens then you will see
you will not at all fall sex often
because if you have temperature
you still have to go
if it's summer you still go right
now a lot of people don't go it's a
little hot outside they don't go on work
little cold outside they don't go on
work a little raining they won't go on
work a snowflake they will not go on
work
this is just weather
so for every change in weather
if you have the comfort of covering
yourself in a blanket and lying down
once you create that
your body will learn to fall sick
as often as possible
if you just keep it this way it doesn't
matter
what it is anyway i have to go and do
what i have to do you will see your body
will just bounce back
as quickly as possible even if it gets
the worst kind of infections
so you just have to set the necessary
conditions for health
necessary in incentives for health both
for yourself and your children if you
have them
do not set incentives for sickness
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this one but the quality of
your life is essentially determined by
how you carry this one
yes or no
this moment
what kind of clothes you're wearing
what kind of car you parked outside what
kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life
this moment how joyful are you feeling
within yourself determines the quality
of your life isn't it so
nothing has been done about it
you think it will happen in consequence
and you're setting impossible goals for
your happiness
if i have to be happy my wife should be
like this my husband should be like that
my children should be like this the
world should become some other way
well these are impossible conditions
you're setting for your happiness and
peacefulness
now that you have compromised yourself
to peace
why i'm saying compromise yourself to
pieces
because a lot of people have given up
aspirations for being ecstatic or
blissful if i'm just peaceful it's
enough
even the so-called spiritual leaders are
going about and saying peace is the
highest goal in your life
peace is not the highest goal in your
life
if you want to enjoy your lunch today
you must be peaceful
yes or no
if you're not even peaceful there is
nothing in your life that you can do in
a worthwhile way
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind
to be peaceful means
that your system is at ease
you know how to conduct your mind you
know how to conduct your emotions your
body and your energies you are peaceful
it is not a rocket technology
it is the most basic thing you have a
dog at home
you give him his food he sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but peacefully many
times they're ecstatic also
yes
if your dog is able to sit pieces oh he
doesn't have to run my industry
that's not the point he's got his own
stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do
with the internal systems as to how
they're functioning essentially it means
either neither your body nor your mind
or your chemistry nor your emotions nor
energy are taking instructions from you
they're doing their own thing
once your machine is not in your control
being peaceful is impossible i'll tell
you you get into your car
and now you go there and you want to
turn this way you do this to the
steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you
no anxiety is natural isn't it
this is what has happened to your
vehicle it's out of control
you've never done anything to find out
where the steering wheel is first of all
this is not that simple as a car this is
a super super computer now the problem
is most people have not even bothered to
find the keyboard
they think if they do this somehow it
will work
if you make when you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine if you do
not conduct it properly
it will cause many problems to you
by accident it's working i want you to
know this this is made this way if you
hold your hands like this it'll breathe
one way if you just turn it around the
very way you breathe the breathing
pattern itself changes in your lungs you
can try it if you want when you have the
time this way this way i'm saying
everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine
it's more than a touch screen if you
just wish it it will happen
when you have such a sensitive and
sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith
then being peaceful seems to be
difficult
peace is not the highest goal in your
life it is the most fundamental
requirement don't ever set peace as the
highest goal if you do that you will
only rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it
if you want to do anything sensibly in
your life if you want to do conduct any
situation in your life sensibly to be
peaceful and happy is fundamental of all
the pieces of engineering on this planet
of many pieces of engineering a tree is
a fantastic engineering even a mountain
is fantastic engineering
because it stood there for a million
years that means it must be good
engineering isn't it
yes
something that stands there for a
million years must be well engineered
of all this the most sophisticated piece
of engineering is human mechanism
isn't it so
hello
most sophisticated of all the pieces of
engineering
now because it's a sophisticated piece
of engineering
it needs a certain level of attention
otherwise you don't figure it
now that we gave you such a highly
you know high-tech
piece of engineering
i'm asking you
did you read the uses menu
i i think there is no user manual or now
how can that make such a fantastic piece
of engineering without a user's manual
maybe it doesn't come
with a booklet attached to your neck
when you were born
but indications must be there isn't it
how to use it
huh
is it true
somebody who's an athlete or a gymnast
or someone else like that
learns to use their body
than a whole lot of other people
yes
obviously
at least one aspect of the physical
engineering of the body
they seem to have read the user's manual
about the physical aspects
is it true certain people are able to
use their mind better than others
maybe they read another part of the
user's manual
so
now uh
with this
heart manual and the brain manual
see the problem is most people are
prejudiced against the brain
this is a question or always comes to me
sadhguru i want to meditate but thoughts
are coming
the common question everywhere
i ask them see i'll make you meditate
we will stop the liver we'll stop the
kidney we'll stop the heart we'll stop
everything okay
so you want the liver to function when
you're meditating
you wonder kidneys to function you want
even the spleen to function you want the
heart to function but you don't want
your brain to function for some reason
this is simply because
brain is a new equipment that you got in
the evolutionary process
this level of cerebral development
happened more recently compared to the
other systems
if you cut open
any mammal they all have all these parts
isn't it every part that you have here
all of them have
even if you open a frog
most of you your biology department
even if you open a frog almost
everything that you have
he also has isn't it
it is only the big difference is only
the cerebral development which is a more
recent happening
because it's a more recent happening
most people have not figured how to
handle it
so user's manual is very important
you don't read a user's manual
just before you discard the machine you
read it
in the first few days isn't it
hello
if you buy a phone do you want to read
the user's manual in the first three
days or after three years when you're
throwing it away
first three days isn't it
so
knowing how this functions is very
important never did ever
heart generate any thought or intention
well when you looked at the young girl
heartbeat
more
that doesn't mean it's saying anything
it's just trying to compensate for the
other levels of excitement that's
happening
you talked one time i thought this was
so interesting about
how every time you get a belief it's
like a conclusion and every conclusion
is a death unto itself and it's like
shutting a door on something yes
otherwise see you just see
you look at your own picture when you're
five years of age it's like this
slowly it's becoming like this what is
it you're dying in installments
the more conclusions you make the less
alive you become
this is all that's happened to people
they call this knowledge
this is not knowledge
this is just conclusions that you're
drawing about
everything see with all this scientific
exploration the fact is
that even today we do not know one
single atom in its entirety
we know how to use them
we know how to use everything on this
planet but we don't know a damn thing
about anything
over 90 percent
or 99
of an atom is empty we don't know what
that emptiness contains
over 99 of the cosmos is empty we don't
know what that is
so
this is like
i give you a million piece jigsaw
but you found
in your hands you have only three of
them with these three you make a picture
and you're euphoric that you made a
picture
well i'm sorry
there are million pieces to this
has anybody gathered all the pieces
no
then don't make a picture when it comes
to what you want to do
uh
you must think clearly it's very
important
thinking clearly means
the question is not about what will get
me this what will get me that
are you is your life precious to you all
of you i'm asking your life is it
precious to you
so before you invest this life
into something
you must look
whether today if i invest my life into
this after 25 years will it still mean a
lot to me
after 50 years will it still mean a lot
to me at the end of my life you turn
back and i look will i be proud of this
or will i be ashamed of what i am doing
right now
it doesn't matter what other people say
but you should not do anything that you
will feel ashamed of isn't it so
it doesn't matter people say so many
things
everybody has opinion it's their
business
but you don't do something that you will
feel ashamed of isn't it
then you're going turning against
yourself
somebody turns against you you can leave
them and go somewhere else
if you turn against yourself you'll have
to live with it forever
so this is all you have to look at it
somebody something will get you money
something will get you comfort that's
not the point
what you choose to do will it give you a
life
when i say give it give your life
are you just trying to make a living or
are you trying to make a life out of
this
this is important
making a living is not an issue
a worm a insect a bird an animal all of
them are making their life making a
living isn't it so
they're even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not an issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
i want to live is not a problem i want
to live like you this is a problem
so
it is important if you consider
your life as a precious life
you must make sure you make a wonderful
life out of this i can show you
thousands of people around me today
when they came
they thought they won't do anything
significant half of them
not half
seventy percent of them are dropouts
from schools and colleges and everything
but
you will see after a few years of
sadhana
suddenly they are functioning in ways
that you won't believe possible
recently we had a business uh you know
event called insight where over 200 ceos
from across the world are coming and
participating
all of them wonder
why our organizations don't run as
smoothly and efficiently as yours
i said that's because i all have all
dropouts who are no good for anything
but
they have devotion in their heart
they're devoted to what they're doing
that's all
because they're absolutely devoted to
what they are doing they may not be mbas
they may not be from iits and ims they
are simple people but because they're
absolutely devoted they do wonderful
things
if you focus whatever you're doing right
now it doesn't matter what it is
how simple an act you're doing right now
it doesn't matter
if you're absolutely devoted to that
that you're doing right now
depending upon various aspects
things will unfold
but
because of western influences we become
too goal oriented
goal oriented means
we are interested in the consequence but
we are not interested in the process
if you are not interested in the process
you should not be an artist
yes
process is an end in itself
if you are absolutely devoted to the
process
depending upon various aspects
something will come out
but now we are interested in the
consequence
not in the process this goal
orientedness i want to get there i want
to get there where the hell do you want
to get
no i want to win the
race see if you treat life as a race
if you have to win it
you have to get to the finish line soon
isn't it
you want to
hello
if you get to the finish line ahead of
all these people you won the race
you know what the finish line is
we'll be negotiating where to bury you
see as we sit here
this is my body that is your body do
what you want these two things will not
become one
this is my mind that is your mind do
what you want these things will not
become one
they may overlap on some issues and we
may feel that we are one with each other
but my mind is my mind your mind is your
mind isn't it
but there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living cosmos
you captured a little bit i captured a
little bit
that's about it
but now we think this is my life and
that is your life there is no such thing
this is a living cosmos you've blown a
small bubble somebody might have blown a
little bigger bubble
did you blow soap bubbles when you are
young oh yeah you still do yes
so when you blew soap bubbles
somebody had this big bubble somebody
else had that big bubble
oh went on saying this is my bubble this
your bubble
but poop it went
once it goes poop
you did not say this is my air and this
is your hair
similarly there is no such thing as my
life and your life
there is just a living cosmos
if you capture more life
then you will see you have more grace
the depth dimension and scope of your
life is determined by how much life you
capture within you
it doesn't matter what kind of body you
have what kind of intelligence you have
if you have not captured substantial
life within you you will live a small
life that's how it is
how do you do this
there are systematic ways of approaching
this
or
simply by involvement and exuberance by
commitment people may capture a larger
life
by absolutely being committed to
something focused on something somebody
may capture a certain amount of life
which is more than what is considered
normal there is thought and there is
emotion
people think these two things are saying
different things they are not saying
different things
the way you think
is the way you emote isn't it so
right now if i think oh she's the most
wonderful person on the planet
i just have to think
then my emotions become sweet towards
her
now i think she's the most horrible
creature on the planet
now my emotions become nasty
yes or no
i cannot think she's horrible and have
sweet emotions
i cannot think she's wonderful and have
nasty emotions isn't it so
but today i thought she's the most
wonderful person and my sweetness was
flowing
suddenly she did something tomorrow that
i don't like i think she's horrible
thought is agile it changes direction
just like that
emotion is little sappy
it takes time to turn around
so that period you struggle as if there
are two dimensions of
thing happening because thought is
saying one thing emotion is still going
sweet
because it takes time to become nasty
everybody struggles but it catches up or
not after some time
hello
today your thought she's wonderful
sweetness was flowing tomorrow she did
something you don't like you thought
she's horrible
mind the thought is clearly saying she's
horrible but emotions are struggling
because they can't turn quickly
they take time to turn but after a week
or ten days or two months depending on
how deeply you're engaged
after some time emotion catches up with
the thought emotion also says yes she's
not horrible so will it be nasty to our
so they're not speaking different
languages
one is agile another is little
slow in its corners
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
one-on-one i did about karma with
sadguru check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there this is
like
banging your head on a wall which is not
going to break anyway it's your head
which will break what you can change you
do not change what you can craft you do
not do it because all your energy goes
into